devenez tulle de belfast tu allais vous
à dublin pour contrainte c'est la
frontière qui sépare l'irlande du nord
de l'irlande du sud
c'était en 1965 un temps où il était
séparé en deux à temps que les irlandais
ne veulent pas revivre une frontière
intérieure tracé après la création de la
république d'irlande en 1921 ce pays qui
vient de naître
très catholique est amputé de ses terres
au nord qui resteront sous contrôle
britannique et où les protestants sont
majoritaires cette frontière de 1921
c'est la naissance du problème
nord-irlandais un conflit entre les
partisans de la couronne britannique et
les militants de la réunification pour
eux dans l'âme la frontière n'existe pas
n'a jamais existé c'est seulement une
politique une frontière meurtrière
pendant des décennies elle a été un
point de cristallisation du conflit
l'ira groupes paramilitaires qui
luttaient pour l'unification de l'île
utilisait l'irlande du sud comme base
arrière pour préparer ses attentats en
irlande du nord
en tout cas l'armée a décidé depuis
quelques jours d'employer la manière
forte pour s'opposer à cet ennemi
invisible qui s'appelle lira elle barre
la route et fait sauter des âmes
des kilomètres de frontière en réalité
impossible à contrôler dans la région en
général on circule comme on veut il ya
énormément de petits chemins de sentiers
de passage creux
quant aux postes frontières ils se font
régulièrement plastique et et les
douaniers sans toit se réfugient dans
des caravanes 1995 un corps de
cessez-le-feu entre l'ira et le
gouvernement britannique
les armes se taisent les douaniers
s'éclipse la frontière s'ouvre entre les
deux pays depuis six mois
jamais on n'avait vu autant de camions
passaient dans les deux sens sans jamais
être arrêté et c'est cela qui a changé
c'est tranquille et sûr et les gens sont
libres de circuler
mais aujourd'hui avec le brésil cette
frontière dont on voit les vestiges ici
en 2010 cette menace de réapparaître
entre l'irlande membres de l'union
européenne et le royaume uni qui n'en
fera bientôt plus partie la frontière
nigel et eric l'un des éleveurs laitiers
la connais très bien
elle traverse même son exploitation
c'est cette rivière qui sépare ces deux
corps de ferme
l'un se trouve en république d'irlande
l'autre en irlande du nord
[Musique]
est-ce que je vais devoir franchir un
checkpoint ou un poste de douane pour me
rendre sur mes deux exploitations
je ne sais pas évidemment personne ne
souhaite revoir les fantômes du passé
mais aucune solution n'a encore été
trouvée
[Musique]
et